there's this war that most people
haven't heard about it's the war in
Bosnia and it happened in like the early
90s big thing that you learn when you
study this war is that the International
Community could have stopped it the UN
was actually there trying to kind of
stop it but they didn't it's easy to
think that the UN is like this big like
Global police manner like that it has
some power but the UN is just composed
of a bunch of countries U.N soldiers are
just soldiers from other countries that
the country sent to be a part of the UN
in the early 90s there weren't a lot of
countries who wanted to get involved in
a conflict in Bosnia so because of this
the UN presence in Bosnia didn't really
affect much it didn't stop terrible
things from happening it's one of
several instances in the 1990s that the
UN could have stepped in and stopped
horrible things from happening but
didn't and we learned big lessons from
that we made a whole video about this
actually and mapped the whole thing and
it's just pretty wild to see how the
world can fail stop something so
horrible from happening